– Hey! Spinnst du?
– Selma, es tut mir leid …
– Was soll das?
– Warum antwortest du mir nicht? Ich hab
dir geschrieben, dich angerufen und …
– Das hab ich gesehen.
– Ich ... ich versteh einfach nicht,
was los ist.
Entweder du sagst mir,
warum du mir nicht antwortest,
oder ich bleib den ganzen Tag
hier vor deinem Haus stehen.
– Nico, wovon sprichst du?
– Ich will einfach nicht,
dass es irgendwelche
Missverständnisse zwischen uns gibt.
Hab ich was Falsches gesagt?
– Nico, ich …
– Ich weiß, entweder wir treffen uns
heimlich in der WG oder in der Stadt, aber …
aber ich musste dich sehen.
Deshalb bin ich gekommen.
– Du hast nichts falsch gemacht, Nico.
Es hat nichts mit dir zu tun.
Wir dürfen uns nicht treffen, Nico.
Meine Eltern erlauben es nicht.
– Ich weiß, aber …
– Ich kann nicht mehr lügen, Nico.
Ich fühl mich so …
so unglaublich schlecht. Gerade jetzt.
Meine Eltern dürfen sich
jetzt nicht aufregen.
– Aber was ist denn passiert, hm?
– Mein Vater ist wieder im Krankenhaus.
– Was?
– Er hatte einen Herzinfarkt
und muss operiert werden.
– Das tut mir leid.
Aber es ist nicht deine Schuld.
– Es tut mir leid, Nico.